what we have here are two different
visualizations of a country's output at
different points in time you might
recognize here on the Left we have a
production possibilities curve for this
country it's a very simple country that
either produces forks and/or spoons so
if it could produce all forks
efficiently it would be right here that
many Forks if it could produce all
spoons efficiently it would be right
here and all the combinations of forks
and spoons that it would produce
efficiently at its potential well that's
what defines this production
possibilities curve on the right here we
have this country's real GDP versus time
and so you could view their real GDP as
some way of computing their aggregate
production of spoons and forks now we
know that real economies do a lot more
than just produce two goods they produce
millions of goods and services but then
you would need a graph that would have
millions of dimensions which is very
hard for most of our brains to
understand but what we have here is
thinking about three different scenarios
at three different times for this
country and we're going to connect the
dots between the visualization on the
left the production possibilities curve
and the visualization on the right and
we're also going to think about other
economic indicators other than real GDP
and how those might play out so let's
start off at time T sub one right over
here from what we know of production
possibility curve x' what is going on in
the economy pause this video and try to
think about that well we know that if
you're on your production possibilities
curve you're operating at your potential
but here we have a situation where we
are operating beyond our potential this
is not a sustainable situation this is a
situation where some people would argue
the economy is overheating this is like
if you on your personal life if you're
pulling all-nighters in order to study
for a test that is not a sustainable
situation but at T sub-1 when you're
operating above your potential it is
associated with low unemployment and
many would argue unsustainably low
unemployment and because there's so much
demand for labor there's so much demand
for utilization of other resources that
that could increase price pressure so
it's also associated with higher in flay
ssin now what would time T sub-1 what
could that be on this graph here well I
already depicted it it could be this
point right over here where our real GDP
is above this horizontal red line which
you could view is our potential GDP our
full employment GDP our full employment
output and so this shows that we have a
positive output gap just as when we're
above or beyond our PPC that is also a
positive output gap now sometimes we
associate this positive output gap being
performing beyond the potential as being
associated with an expansion versus a
recession and it is indeed the case that
this T sub one is happening during an
expansion an expansion is situation
where the GDP is growing so this is an
expansion here and then if we go from
the next trough to the next peak this is
an expansion here and the opposite of an
expansion is a recession so this is a
recession when we're going from a peak
to a trough and if we go from the next
peak to the next trough that also would
be a recession so this positive output
gap is happening during an expansion but
you could have a situation where you're
right here where you have a positive
output gap where you're operating beyond
your potential but the economy has
started to shrink so it's not always the
case
even though positive output gaps get
associated with the expansions it's not
always during an expansion but anyway
let's move forward in time let's say for
various reasons our economy slows down a
bit and we go to time T sub 2 now we are
actually operating at potential we are
at our productions possibility curve and
so what point could that be on this
graph well we have it depicted right
here at time T sub 2 the country is
operating exactly at its potential the
country is operating efficiently in a
sustainable way and then we go to time T
sub 3 so times T sub 3 is
clear that we have a negative output gap
and you can see it over here as well we
have a negative output gap and if you
think about the economic indicators
other than real GDP what would they be
doing this is a situation where an
economy is operating below full
employment where the unemployment rate
could be elevated or it's typically
elevated when you have this negative
output gap and because both the labor
and oftentimes other resources aren't
being fully utilized there might not be
a lot of price presser so in this
situation inflation would be lower and
in extreme cases you could even have
negative inflation which we would call
deflation now associated with all of
these ideas is the idea of economic
growth so in everyday language when
people talk about economic growth
they're usually talking about expansions
they're talking about situations where
real GDP is growing but economists when
they talk about economic growth do not
mean that to an economists economic
growth is when the potential of an
economy increases and we know that the
only way that the potential of an
economy increases is if they all of a
sudden have more factors of production
better resources better technology the
population has increased so economic
growth would be associated with pushing
out the actual PPC so this would if you
somehow they had more technology or more
people now so now that would push out
the PPC and economic growth for example
if this red line which is the country's
potential were to increase like this
that would be economic growth the actual
real GDP at any given time would likely
cycle around that